[Musica]
avete prima imparato a leggere oa
parlare
la domanda è retorica
sicuramente avrete prima imparato a
parlare poi con la scolarizzazione vi è
stato insegnato a leggere ea scrivere
quando i vostri maestri vi hanno
insegnato a leggere e scrivere
sicuramente sono partiti da parole di
cui voi conoscevate il significato non
faccio scrivere un bambino una parola
che non può comprendere inizio a
insegnargli a leggere scrivere dalla
parola up e dalla parola balena eccetera
eccetera è scontato quello che sto
dicendo ma purtroppo per qualche motivo
nell'insegnamento della musica
questa accortezza non ci è stata data
spesso cioè vi hanno insegnato
probabilmente a scuola con il flauto di
plastica che ricorderete molti di voi
ricorderanno come un incubo
vi hanno insegnato partendo dalle note
c'è dalla forma grafica di cose di cui
non avevate un'esperienza diretta in
segno come si scrive il dott
ma tu non l'hai mai fatto non l'hai mai
vissuto non sai che cosa quel d'oro e
allora da qui viene probabilmente per
molti di voi la frustrazione della
musica a scuola e ci sarà stato qualche
insegnante che vi ha detto non siete
portati per la musica a me è stato detto
più di una volta non è così vi hanno
ingannato soprattutto quell'insegnante
che ve lo ha detto non era portato per
fare l'insegnante di musica
probabilmente era un grandissimo
musicista io questo non lo so ma non
sapeva insegnare la musica
ma tanta acqua sotto i ponti da quando
questo signore ha inventato una
metodologia per insegnare la musica ai
bambini
carl orff compositore dei famosi carmina
burana sostanzialmente ci dice che i
bambini amano giocare e non amano
studiare quindi se tu gli vuoi insegnare
qualche cosa devi fare in modo di
insegnargliela giocando e lui
chiaramente parlava della musica ma in
realtà questa cosa si può applicare a
tutte le conoscenze umane dalla sua
metodologia ne viene una classe che è
completamente diversa nelle mie classi
nelle mie aule i ragazzi i bambini non
hanno banco e non hanno sedia quindi
sono liberi
nello spazio si possono muovere ma
soprattutto si va a ribaltare quel
teorema per cui il professore sta sulla
cattedra e tutti gli allievi sotto
imparano nelle mie aule si sta in
cerchio e si condivide un'esperienza
un'esperienza che ha tantissime forme
perché la musica non sono solo suonare
uno strumento musica e anche cantare
ballare
oppure percuotere il corpo
questa era body percussion
io lo utilizzo nei miei laboratori a
scuola perché il corpo è la prima cosa
che l'essere umano ha suonato non ha
costruito un violoncello il primo uomo
sulla terra ma ha suonato il proprio
corpo e il corpo lo hai sempre con te
non costa nulla
non te lo dimentichi sull'autobus
quindi io quando iniziò a lavorare con i
bambini inizia dal corpo questo insegna
anche la coordinazione nei movimenti
importantissimo la musica è un gioco e
come tutti i giochi si fa insieme agli
altri
avete l'idea del pianista che impara da
solo nella sua stanza con un mozzicone
di candela e passa le sue giornate a
fare scale ecco quel sistema lì magari
formerà qualche bravo musicista ma ne
ambienterà tantissime se io faccio
giocare i bambini li faccio giocare
insieme e insieme condividiamo
un'esperienza di gioco musicale questo
azzera la frustrazione e gli abbandoni
nei conservatori ci sono percentuali di
abbandono altissima come imparo allora
come faccio a fermare dei concetti i
concetti si fermano nella mente dei
bambini quando sono legati alle emozioni
sicuramente tutti voi avrete in mente
una lezione di un vostro insegnante e se
ve la ricordate è perché lui in qualche
modo è riuscito a farli emozionare con
la musica si fa presto perché la musica
veicola le emozioni
allora io uso sempre
musiche importanti quando lavoro con i
bambini non uso le classiche musiche per
bambini perché non ha senso la musica
per bambini la musica è musica esiste
musica di buona qualità e musica magari
con qualità inferiore
ma la musica brutta la sentite tutti i
giorni continuamente basta accendere la
radio la televisione un jingle
pubblicitario la musica buona è quella
che ti fa emozionare ed ha anche un un
linguaggio più complesso se io insegna
un bambino la musica come un linguaggio
gli devo fornire parole diverse
allora si usa il jazz allora si usano i
pink floyd
allora si usa la musica delle
percussioni africane una ricchezza
culturale musicale questo trasmette le
emozioni e come abbiamo detto se ti
emozioni non te lo dimentichi più
sicuramente tutti voi si ricorderanno
dove erano la notte in cui l'italia ha
vinto i mondiali e berlino che cosa
hanno fatto con chi erano e forse anche
che cosa hanno mangiato perché quell
emozione per voi rende quella giornata
indelebile
bene allora se io costruisco un tipo di
classe gestita in questo modo qua e
chiedo ai ragazzi e ai bambini di creare
di usare la loro creatività di
emozionarsi allora poi non posso dirgli
quello che hai creato e sbagliato nelle
mie aule l'errore non esiste perché
attraverso gli errori che si crea al
progetto
il programma e la la creatività io posso
costruire qualcosa
sbagliando continuamente e aggiustando
il tiro continuamente se dico che
l'errore non esiste elimino
immediatamente la frustrazione
elimino quel
non sei portato per la musica perché
tutto quello che tu realizzi tutto
quello che il bambino riesce a inventare
magari con dei piccoli strumenti a
percussione o o con canto o col
movimento del corpo è giusto è la sua
espressione
facendo questo nella nell'aula si crea
indubbiamente una notevole inclusione e
guardate l'inclusione non serve solo per
allievi che hanno determinate necessità
l'inclusione serve a tutti perché magari
un giorno ci svegliamo tristi
arriviamo a scuola e abbiamo bisogno di
sentirci abbracciati dagli altri di
sentirci inclusi
questo vale per tutti allora io a un
certo punto ho pensato se come avevo
anche delle degli allievi più grandi
degli allievi adulti che venivano ai
miei corsi ho pensato ma se tutta questa
cosa funziona con i bambini ma allora
forse funzionerà anche con gli adulti
perché ci sono degli adulti che vengono
a suonare nei miei corsi le percussioni
che non hanno mai suonato in vita loro
no magari a il flauto alle medie
allora ho detto se funziona con i
bambini deve poter funzionare con tutti
e mi sono reso conto nel tempo che senza
se e senza ma visto che il tema di oggi
tutti ma proprio tutti possono suonare
uno strumento
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
c'è chi
[Risate]
[Applauso]
grazie
vedrò samba
potete venire tutti a suonare con noi
se volete vedrà samba grazie grazie